hello belief nation I'm Evan Carmichael
my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems I
started to mentor me series with the
goal to try to learn from people who've
done a lot more than as people who have
done amazing things that by spending a
little bit more time with them hopefully
some of their values their belief
systems their way of thinking
seeped into us to help us become the
best version of ourselves so today we're
going to learn from Bishop TD jakes and
some of his best motivation mentor me
Bishop Jake's rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down in the
comments below it and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
to enjoy
[Music]
you
life's demand said you pick up the pace
if you don't pick up the pace you're
gonna be left behind I'm amazed that the
people that lack the flexibility to pick
up the pace they just get in a read I
scroll down here and I'm gonna scroll
back and go stroll over here and go
stroll over there one of the most
amazing thing about the disaster at
Malaysia is that when it happened
everybody had to pick up the pace all
the news media had to pick up the pace
they were booking night flights and
flying over here flying over there
somebody had to work overtime won't be
home for three days typing in the middle
of night research going on because when
something happens body gotta pick up the
pace that's why I can't deal with people
who cannot pick up the pace don't be
strolling when I got a 9-1-1 on you and
the people who can pick up the pace
slightly david said pick up the pace
something's about to happen pick up the
pace something's about to happen pick up
the pace something's about to happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen pick up the pace something's
about to have it I came to tell the
young people pick up the place pick up
the pace pick up the plate something
about the danger of low expectations
I would rather aim for the stars and not
hit them then should not aim at all I
would rather go after it and not get it
did not go after it at all I'd rather
try and fail did not try at all I don't
want to live with the idea wonder what
would have happened had I done more with
my life
I'm gonna go for it come hell or high
water I'm going after my destiny since
the neighbors say run do not run after
your destiny you can't stroll after your
destiny
you can't walk after your destiny you
gotta run
somebody ha
you gotta run you gotta run
you gotta run you can't just wake up in
the morning let me see what's gonna
happen today I don't know what I'm gonna
do I don't know what I'm aware don't
know what I'm oh cool I don't know where
I'm gonna go I just woke up
oh you should stay in the bed give the
day to somebody who's gone wrong after
their destiny give the day to somebody
who has a plan who has a strategy
because success is never an accident and
if you don't want it get out of my way
because there are some people who want
to do something with their life Ron Paul
writes to Timothy and says our Father
good fight let me know being me is not
easy it's not for the faint of heart
it's not in my suit you can get so
slightly but they won't make you stand
like me I fought a good fight baby
I fought one hell of a fight I landed
fighters in here
[Applause]
slap somebody intellimouse fought a good
fight
[Applause]
I [ __ ] my way up I fought to get to
work I've fought to get up on my feet
I've fought to stare I fought to carry
on I fought to love I fought to live I
fought to get out the bed I fought with
my fears my doubts my anxieties my
insecurities have fought with haters
Liars
back biters and betrayers I even had to
fight with family and many times I laid
in the bed I couldn't go to sleep cuz I
was fighting with myself I know I put
anything what it takes to withstand the
pressure slap your neighbors say you
don't know what you got you don't know
what you've got until all hell breaks
loose you don't know what you can take
until the pressure is applied to your
life you don't know what you can endure
in people until people stab you in the
back and walk away from you you don't
know how much courage you have until
you've been under fire and I'm their
struggle and them to tribulation you
can't learn what's in you sitting back
in the lazy boy chair hit the remote
control watching HBO and Cinemax but
when all hell breaks loose
that's when you get to see
[Applause]
what you got touched it neighbours say
I'm made of something
I didn't get to see the design I didn't
get to see the architectural players but
I know I made us some good stuff I can
tell by the burdens out there and the
load I carry and the stuff I endure I
shot myself at what I'm able to tape
it's not just that I sucked my enemies I
shot myself
they said I was gonna die and I believed
it but through hell and high water to be
anxious is to have anxiety about
something that hadn't even happened yet
some of you are so worried by the threat
of trouble you're not in trouble it's
just the trouble has threatened you what
could happen it's wearing you now
careful the things that you thought were
going to happen
never did happen but if you
those spots to dwell in your mind it
will succeed and robbing you of your
peace robbing you of your joy robbing
you of your life just because you lock
yourself into a nervous breakdown
yourself into the person you've got
yourself into defeatism the mind is the
battleground the fight is in your mind
so I want to challenge you to waste no
more effort wrestling with other people
I lost you
your destiny your future is not
predicated on the decision of someone
else you've wasted too much
trying to change other people's mind
the
a lot of what they think about you
bless you by their opinion god bless you
but how do you see
but somebody say I believe I'm coming
out
I'm going to lose
they shall never
somebody
I lost a lot of stuff I lost a lot of
friends I lost a lot of strength I lost
a lot of courage I lost a lot of time I
lost a lot of money but I kept down on
my knees I was still believing broke I
was believing lonely I was believing
betrayed
Chuck
test 3 Fremont um keep the faith keep
the faith
if you lose the job keep the faith if
you lose the spouse keep the faith if
you're bearing your child keep the faith
if you have to downsize keep the faith
if you have to move in with your mama
keep the faith if you had to witzy and
keep the faith if you have to catch the
bus
keep the faith if you have to come keep
the faith
if you get sick keep the faith if you
lose the kidneys keep the faith if you
got a heart trouble
keep the faith you might not get a new
heart but you gotta keep your faith have
you ever notice of when your faith is as
strong as you come up under the greatest
attack because every time the devil
senses that you're about to walk into
who you be he knows next you gonna do
something and he's trying to stop you
from doing it slap somebody say just do
it
the enemy's trying to stop you from
doing it because every time you have a
big moment he trusted decoy you because
as soon as you figure out who you are
you're gonna do exploit slap somebody's
I got something to do as well he'll is
breaking loose it but I forgot something
to do that's why I keep going to storms
and setbacks I got something to do
that's why I keep getting sick in my
body I got something too that's why the
devil keeps bringing up my past
cuz I got something too
he's trying to break my heart to be
planted is destiny concealed to have
increase is destiny reveal so when you
plant a seed you don't plant it as if
the planting were the final destination
you plant it and you can't see it
anymore
it's destiny is concealed in the hopes
that ultimately it will become a stalk
of corn or an apple tree or whatever it
was you plan it and in between the
destiny conceal and the destiny reveal
is something we call watering and I
thought as dynamic as the text maybe to
crumple with the notion of being planted
and to grumble with the notion of having
increase seems totally irrelevant if we
don't stop by the station of watering
because watering is the last step before
increase it is a transition point
between what is concealed and what is
revealed and without the benefit of
watering this the thedestiny will die in
the ground never reaching its potential
simply because it has never been watered
and I thought I would ask you this
morning have you ever been watered I'm
reading somebody's mail right
you cannot embrace what I'm about to
teach if you don't understand that you
have been planted you didn't grow wild
you didn't just happen you aren't just
an afterthought you didn't just come to
be you were planted the sperm cell that
created you out swam all of the millions
of other cells before you had a Bible
before you had a Bible before you had a
hymnbook
you are already in a fight and that cell
elsewhere of all the rest because you
have been planted well I want to make
the distinction about being planted
because the act of planting can be
confusing to the student who has not
watched because planting looks no
different from burial
[Applause]
in order to do the one of them you got
to do some digging and once you dig down
in the ground both of them are concealed
but one of them has a destiny and the
other one does not you bury the dead to
get rid of the body
but you plant a seed so that it can go
through a transformation of coming back
up greater than it was when it went down
oh good god reversal that's so good I'm
gonna come over here and say it again
when you plant a seed
you're not burying it to get rid of it
you're planting it so that it can go
through a metamorphosis and come back up
better than it was when it went down how
many people in this room has come up
better than you were
I'm better I'm better I'm better than a
walls want to went down it was good for
me that I've been afflicted for had I
not been afflicted I would have never
known the glory of God I'm better for it
I didn't like it but I'm better for it I
couldn't see down there but I'm better
for it
you said I was planted in a dark place
where my sight didn't work for me but
I'm better for every time you go through
something dark and you can't see your
way out remember you've been planted not
been buried and with you karma
I'm coming out I'm coming up brother
right here on the come up except brother
right here on the come up is any sisters
in here on the come up related families
in here on the come up are they the
preachers it here on the come up you
already been through hell already been
through hot water already been planted
already been in a dark place but just
cuz I'm in a dark place don't expect me
to stay in a dark place brother right
here
[Applause]
write yourself a note I have not been
buried I have been planted I may be
underground but I'm not buried in this
mess I'm planted in it
I'm planted in it and if I planted in it
expect me to come back up again and when
I come back up you won't recognize me
because I'm gonna be transformed by the
experiences that I have to do when you
talk to women about birth they
immediately think about being mothers
but I didn't come to talk to you as
mothers I came to talk to you as babies
who have outgrown the parameters of the
home that you live in I came to talk to
you as living creatures who have found
restrictions in the place that you once
found nurture and nourishment and found
yourself in prison by narrow thinking
people and narrow thinking circumstances
and narrow evolving predicaments I came
to tell you that you cannot feed in one
realm and stay in that realm that if you
get enough on the inside of you you will
find a discomfort in staying in the
dimension that you once lived in and I
came to prepare your hearts and mind if
you're not prepared to go through some
bloody stuff and some dirty stuff and
some stinky stuff you don't want to keep
feeding on this kind of word because if
you feed on this kind of word it will
open up your mind and over
you're thinking and opening up your
ideas and open up your concept until all
of a sudden you are uncomfortable in
what you were once comfortable in some
of you have already begin to experience
your thinking on another level and if
it's causing a separation some of you
have already begin to experience it
because what used to be funny isn't
funny anymore what you used to enjoy you
don't enjoy anymore and what you used to
be satisfied with you're not satisfied
with anymore and all of a sudden you
don't sit in the places you used to fit
in and you don't even understand it and
they think you're acting funny and they
think you're acting strange and they say
things like you forgot what are you
paying from I didn't forget it I just
can't stay in it
[Applause]
tweet that tweet then I got to get out
of here I got to get out of here I got
to get out of here I got to get out of
here I got to get out of here I've got
to get out of here I've got to get out
of here you tell your twin you can stay
in there if you want to this might be
okay for you but I've got to get out of
here even if I have to fight my way out
like Jacob and Esau I've got to get out
there if I've got the pool and I've got
to get out I've got too much visa to
stay in this what the hardest thing to
do the hardest thing to deal with the
hardest thing to manage the hardest
thing to put up with is transition the
thing we hate the most is transition we
hate it because it takes us out of our
element it takes us out of our comfort
zone it takes us out of the place where
we are secure and sure and we've learned
how to manage and control everything you
cannot control everything when you are
in transition it is what it is it
happens like it happens I can't be
pretty about it I can't meet with the
board or talk to the committee or get
everybody to approve it when my water
breaks get ready here if it's under a
tree it sits under a bus if it's against
the wall with the water breaks that's my
son here cut two neighbors head moves
Moo's and rolled out of this spot moves
I'm coming into another dimension move I
see a door opening for me move
I see the vine permissiveness step moves
I see the glory of God calling me if
enough people like me then I am how many
people following you on Twitter I got to
get my following up I got to get my
friends up because if I have popularity
who you got quite again if if I let me
show you how many people follow me
do you know Bishop start a fire bother
me
[Applause]
so I am because of who follows me who
Laxmi popularity base identity ooh
performance based identity if you do
this you'll be the fan of God if they
like you
you'll be the Son of God if I give you
my possessions you'll be now let me show
you something I'm teaching just do it
okay
and yet I'm criticizing doing it to
define who you are
well I'm confused should I do it a lot
good you did you just said just do it
and then you turned around and said not
to define myself by what I do
cannot retreat my old text which way is
it revin do I do it or not do it the
problem is not about doing it it is why
you do it what I am criticizing is
putting the doing before the beam so
that you think that if I do this I will
be somebody if I bad this I will be
somebody if they like me I will be there
you got it backwards the people that
know their God shall do and because
you're doing doesn't come from the
deeper place of being it hasn't worked
for you because you are who you are you
can do what you can do but if you're
trying to find out who you are by doing
things you will never find out who you
are by doing you have to start with
being so are you are you getting and I
want you to see this I don't want to
lose you this because the difference
between the two determines the direction
of your destiny if you're always seeking
a certain status to validate who you are
you're never gonna have peace you have
to know who you are and then you can
climb to the status you can't climb up
to find yourself you have to find
yourself so you can climb up
you can't climb up to find yourself you
have to find yourself so you can climb
up so you can be who you are before
anybody knows who you are
so that means you could be rich while
you broke
you can you can be healed while you sick
you can be loosed why are you bad it
does not yet appear what you sell me it
hasn't sold up what you sell me but you
got to be it
before you can get it woman no it looks
like you're tired up I know you're over
for 18 years I know your conditions
don't validate you but let me tell you
about who you are not gonna be loose not
savvy knows you are loosed on the inside
before your
[Applause]
[Applause]
I came to deliver a message to every
person in this room who's had a struggle
who's had some pains who's had some
tests who's got some creative ideas but
you've gone through some really tough
stuff let me tell you some of the stuff
you've been through don't pay it any
attention it is just a sign that the
baby is coming you're on the verge of
birthday you're on the verge of birthday
you're on the verge of birthday you're
about to give birth I want you to touch
everybody you can reach and tell them
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming the baby is coming
the baby is coming
the baby is coming you don't want to
leave me now the baby is coming you
don't want to walk out on me now the
baby is coming I haven't had my best
idea yet I haven't had my most creative
moment yet I haven't produced my dream
yet I don't care whether you're 30 40 50
60 70 there's something bound inside of
you that's still kicking inside of you
that wants to get out and it wants to
live
it wants to laugh the whole reason
you're here today is because there's
something in you that needs to be fed
that needs to be stern that needs to be
electrified that is to be illuminators
that something's down sorry
[Applause]
for you to give birth to the greatest
[Music]
[Applause]
she was going to listen they're gonna
miss it they're gonna miss the greatest
part of you the greatest part of your
destiny the greatest part of your
creativity it took everything you went
through yesterday to get you ready for
what you are about to do today you are
standing on the verge of a Great
Awakening or you wouldn't be here if I'm
talking to you make some noise in this
foot
[Applause]
here
believe their businesses in you
companies in you concepts in you books
to be written paintings to be drawn
concepts to be birth ideas creative
concepts there's something that you
could do that you could think in your
life that would radically change your
life somebody could take the hand you've
been built and win with it same
circumstances same ideas they would do
it through what they thought about your
life but we don't need somebody cuz we
got you we got you you're the one you
are the one I want you to join hands in
some way for just a minute I'm telling
you right now if you are going to birth
your dream you're calling your passion
and the second half of your life you
can't draw back when life gets tough
you've got to stand up to it and push
get that person by the hand because
there's something inside of them that is
about to happen squeeze their hand
[Applause]
and when I count to three I want every
man and every woman that's got a concept
that's got an idea
I want you to push with all of your
might until freeze and concepts and
ideas start to birth out of you in the
middle of the night you will need pins
and pads by your bed tonight to survive
to get up in the middle of the night and
start writing down all the stuff let's
go start coming out of your spirit
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you take from this video that you're
going to immediately apply somehow to
your life or to your business leave it
down the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout-out to surge
wisdom thank you so much you're picking
up a copy of my book through one word
and doing that animated chapter review
on your YouTube channel
I really really really appreciate this
apartment and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the read so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
[Music]
always go to something bigger than
yourself
I'm wondering if you've been defeated
because you have been giving yourself
wholly to something that was too small
to hold you have you thrusts yourself
into a glass of water have you leapt off
the diving board into a cereal bowl
person are you not guilty of immersing
yourself into things that were too small
to hold your vision oh my god this so
good I'm gonna get the CD myself
[Applause]
Jesus sent him to throw himself into
something that was bigger than his
condition and he had to go to get to it
he had to get out of his comfort zone
my problem is so many times you've
thrown big ideas as small people
you've given big commitment to cereal
bowl people and you're trying to get
your sight back from a source that's too
small to support what you're willing to
put in is your investment bigger than
the bank you should see the way you're
looking at me is your is the reason you
keep being disappointed by people is
that you have wholly throw yourself into
something that was too small
Jesus sends him to something that is
bigger than himself so he can wash his
eye are you trying to take a bath in a
bowl